As I said, there are lots
of different color spaces.
Here's a nice picture of
all these different ways of
representing these things.
By the way, notice the one
here at the bottom left, red,
blue, green, red, green, blue.
We'll talk about that one in a minute.
All right, but
let me show you what my favorite.
In fact I'll put up two of them.
So which one's my favorite?
Well, I think I already gave it away.
I told you that the problem
with this one here,
is that the entire top surface is white.
And so, here's the question.
How much can I change the color
of something that's white?
Answer, not at all.
White is white is white.
So that's why I like this idea of
having this peak on the top, so
that is you can't get far away from it.
Likewise, same as, as on the black.
And you spin around,
the double cone gives you the, the hue.
And as you get further out,
they call it chroma.
I actually like calling
it saturation better.
It, it doesn't really matter too much.
But the idea is,
I tend to think of it as a cone.
And what's important is when
you realize that it's a cone,
you realize that if you're comparing,
and we'll get to this in a minute,
if you're comparing the hue
of two different patches,
if they're very dark,
the hue doesn't mean anything.
If they're very bright,
And that's very hard to see on
this cylinder representation, but
it's very easy to see,
see on the, on the cone.
Now of course, what is the color
space that we all know and love,
or at least know?
All right?
Which is the one we know best?
Well, it's the RGB space, right,
where basically, you've got a cube,
where in sort of a back corner where
things are 0, 0, or everything's black.
If you move down the red axis,
it turns red.
If you move to the green axis,
it turns green.
Add them together,
what's red and green make?
Yellow.
Why?
Cones.
And if you bring the whole thing up,
it looks white.
And what's cool is if you take
that cube, and you sort of
pull the white corner to the top and
the black corner to the bottom, right?
So in fact I have a sort of picture,
just think about that,
it would be almost like a double cone.
Not quite, it would be kind of
a lumpy double cone with sharp points.
But the idea is,
white would be at a point on the top,
black would be at a point on the bottom,
right, and then you would have
chroma as you went around.
And that's why my preference
is the double cone.